so here's a question how much of your
brain do you actually use now CERN
Hollywood movies might try and have you
believe that we only use 10% of our
brains doesn't look like much does it
and what does that mean the other 90% is
for just pointless pink mush
hey bad zombie fun science fun science
pond science it's a science of fun yeah
fun fact
we human beings actually use a hundred
percent of our brains obviously so
here's another question how much of your
brain actually makes up you and by you
I'm referring to the little voice inside
of your head your inner monologue your
conscious thoughts I think therefore I
am
now it's hard to know exactly how much
space your conscious mind takes up in
your brain but we definitely know it
isn't the entire thing because there are
many functions your brain does without
you having to think about take breathing
for example yes you can control your
breath when you want to but you don't
have to think about it in order to spare
life located at the base of the brain is
the respiratory control center
he is signals are sent down your spine
to the muscles around your lungs selling
them to tighten and relax regulates so
you can breathe in and out you think
this job is bad you should see the guy
who has to do the heart please don't go
no run today please don't go on a run
today please are going around today
however when it comes to our conscious
mind we're not actually really sure how
it works we know it involves a neural
activity in the front of the cortex as
well as more activity all around the
brain but otherwise we're pretty much
clueless in fact we might even know less
than we think we do because even the
very idea that our mind controls our
body might not be quite as
straightforward as we'd like for example
imagine that you're just chillin minding
your own business when
I appear behind you wearing an elf
costume naturally your heart starts
beating rapidly your stomach tenses ends
[Music]
so what's happening here oh can I do
this one okay so you see me which is
obviously terrifying and that makes you
scared which causes your heart to beat
really quickly and your stomach to tense
up close but not quite
can I have a go okay so I see Charlie
I'm registered him as a clear threat and
so my brain sends messages to my stomach
and hearts telling them to tense up and
be faster respectively
I then notice these changes in my body
and take them as a sign that I should be
afraid of him which I still AM by the
way exactly
nice one can I interest you in a copy of
this book it's the perfect gift for
Christmas so although it might sound
counterintuitive when it comes to your
emotions your brain knows how you should
feel before you do and actually tells
you how to feel by changing your body
how weird is that
however this idea of your brain
controlling you doesn't just apply to
your emotions in fact it might even
apply to something as simple as the
wiggle of a finger in an experiment
which was first done in the 40s people's
brainwaves were measured and they were
told to simply wiggle their finger
whenever they felt like it now instinct
says that you should see something like
this basically because I decided to
wiggle my finger just a fraction of a
second before I actually wiggled it the
point at which I made that decision is
where you'd expect to see brain activity
however well the experiment actually
showed with something more like this
[Music]
now to be clear this is still the point
where I decided to wiggle my finger so
just a fraction of a second before I
actually wiggled it so what the graph
shows is that my brain did something
before I made my choice
almost as if my brain was willing me to
will so is free will just an illusion is
your conscious internal monologue merely
a story that your brain tells yourself
to make you feel like you're in control
well we can't say for certain the finger
wiggling experiment and many others that
have been conducted since definitely do
make it seem that way fortunately there
is a bright side to all of this did we
ever figure out what the bright side was
see you next time thank you so much for
watching everyone also thank you to my
friend Sam for appearing in this video
please do go and subscribe to him I have
one more of these videos coming out it's
almost over but please do watch it stay
tuned and also I wrote a book didn't I
lovely little fun science book no I've
got the face like that on it is it this
is the same outfit that's why I'm doing
that anyway available in all good
bookstores links down in the description
thank you very much and goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool